anyways okay let's continue let's go to
the Buccaneers Antonio Brown obtained
alleged fake covid-19 vaccine card from
teammates page eight uh so he plays for
the bucks okay if you don't know who
this guy is Antonio Brown is a at one
point I think he was the fastest guy in
the NFL on Thursday Tampa Bay Times
report claimed that Tampa Bay Buccaneer
star wide receiver and Tony Brown used a
fake covid-19 vaccination card to get
around certain NFL health and safety
protocols without having to receive one
of the safe and available coronavirus
vaccines I like the way they said one of
the safe and available Chrono vaccine
shots the NFL and its reviewers uh uh uh
the matter but the overall situation
took a different turn Friday when ESPN's
Gina Lane reported Ruiz says Brown
obtained the alleged fake vaccination
car from a Buccaneers teammate he got
them from another player who was selling
them rui said that player came over to
the house multiple times he had to get
another a copy of Brown's girlfriend's
vaccine card because they got her
birthday wrong on the first one faking
or doctoring a covenanting vaccination
card is a federal criminal offense and
also violates the NFL's personal conduct
policy meaning Brown could be fined or
suspended if the league proves of this
ultimately believes ruiz's claims Gerard
thoughts listen you take somebody that's
completely and totally healthy and tell
them that they can't work unless they
inject themselves with something that
they don't want to inject themselves
you're going to create a black market
all right this is this is after this is
right on the heels of Aaron Rodgers all
right where they tried to skew around
Rogers for for his decision why does the
elite media why does the the let's just
call it what it is why why when I was in
in St Louis all right
I posted all about it if people follow
me I posted all about it on and I went
on this whole rant about every place was
closed shut down all right place was hit
hit hard by coven and it was shut down
and the places that weren't shut down
all right there was one place called
gramophone it was like the only place
that was open and in order to get in for
me to get dinner all right it's a
sandwich and beer shop I had to show a
negative coven test within the last 72
hours or a vax card to go inside and eat
a sandwich and I'm out there and the guy
the bouncer who's sitting outside with a
mask on outside I'm like bro
I'm gonna go inside and I'm gonna have a
sandwich no one's sitting in there no
one's around me you you need me to prove
just this I was like What if I have
herpes I'm gonna drink out of this glass
and then on somebody else is going to
drink out of the glass that I'm gonna
drink out of shouldn't I show a negative
test from that the old herpes
them every time you guys prove to me
shouldn't I be able to see that you guys
are cleaning things effectively does
this so anyway I get into this whole
thing with this guy obviously because
you know I had to make a scene about it
I'm just sitting here like wait a minute
man every place is closed every place is
closed here's one guy trying to give you
business and you're saying no no you you
can't come in because you're not obeying
us has nothing to do with health what do
you think is going to happen to Antonio
Brown that's what he thinks there's
nothing to promise he's going to get
suspended I'm fine well I think so
because the NFL needs to make an example
of somebody there's gonna be a fall guy
just like there's a drug test he's an
easy guy to do it too by the way yeah
and if you think about it Antonio
Brown's an easy guy it's not like it's
my homes or it's Brady you can do it to
this guy they didn't suspend Rogers so
they I don't think they can suspend
Antonio Brown
Rogers said what Roger said he had taken
a vaccine
he didn't go so far as the fake passport
yeah that's to differentiator just so
you know guys I've gotten arrested for
having a fake vaccination card just so
you know that so can you Google uh uh
arrested fake vaccination card I
remember a father and a son asian
picture came about like six months ago
where these guys got arrested for having
a fake vaccination card Eleanor woman
arrested over moderna vaccine card yeah
New York man charged with felony for
faking vaccine card yeah this is this is
not like it's a uh seven year in prison
hang on go back to it go back to it
watch this New York man charged with
felony could face seven years in prison
after being accused of Faking a covid-19
vaccine this pisses me off
what I'm what I'm what I'm trying to say
to you is what I'm trying to say to you
is your answer is what they should do to
him that's not my question my question
is what do you think the NFL godell will
be forced to do to Brown he's we have
everything's going to cave and again
they gotta make a Fall Guy because they
got to set up they got a set of
presidents for the rest of the league
just like they do the drug policy you
pop tests for a banned substance and
that your kid whoever is playing is is
gone for the year I think it's going to
happen to AB he's been in and out of the
news teams for a handful of years now
I'm more concerned about his
quote-unquote teammate who was selling
them as a side hustle what kind of guy
out there is that on the teammate being
like look guy you went on fake like
focus on playing blocking and tackling
you don't think that's happening all
over the years
that has a fake vax card yeah this
person had covet didn't want he's
healthy didn't want to get the vax
travels sometimes internationally has a
fake vax card and this is not a
right-winger to say the least he just
wants to be able to do his thing so
you brought up the word black market and
that's exactly what's going on here
anytime that there's rules and
regulations that you don't agree with
you're going to try to skirt the issues
it's just crazy and that's what's going
on here it's just crazy as a felony that
pissed me up because you have a feeling
in your record you can't get a job or
you can get a license not think about
this think about this okay can you sue
them where's accountability lie right
now can you sue them if they get sick if
you get sick can you sue them of course
not you can't no and fire the the FDA
who's supposed to be working on our
behalf just asked a federal court to
withhold the the fo the foi for the the
uh what is it um Freedom of Information
Act 55 years we're all gonna be dead
until we know whether they knew it would
make us sick yeah
55 years man all we've been told is
trust the science trust the science but
you can't read the science until
2075. you know she has made it also a uh
uh you know illegal so where's
accountability accountability is shut up
and do what you're told shut up and do
what you're told by the way you Gerard
said that so quickly can you pull up
that story because uh that's uh you're
coming out with a product that we cannot
Sue here you go this is the this is the
story vaccine vaccine is an injury
attorney FD asked judge to Grant it
until you're in 2006 let me read this
guys FDA asks judge to Grant it until
year 2076 to release Pfizer vaccine data
attorneys 3 publish an update on his
case against the FDA and he wrote the
FDA has asked a federal judge to make
the public wait until the year 2076 to
disclose all of the data information had
relied upon to license Pfizer covid-19
vaccine this is not a typo it wants 55
years to produce this information to the
public so let's get this straight the
federal government Shields Pfizer from
liability gives it billions of dollars
makes Americans take its product but
won't let you see the data supporting
this product safety and efficiency why
does the government who does the
government work for so this is a very
big problem huge to have something like
this setting up for themselves yeah
2076 that's what 50 55 years from now
insane to be able to do that so will
anything happen to him will anything
happening around yes
well he didn't play last night on Monday
Night Football I don't know if he's
injured right now or if he's suspended
currently but he didn't play last night
on Monday Night Football I don't know do
you think the NFL is going to go as far
as suspending him from the season no
okay do you think this is going to be
like a one game or two gamer type of
suspension okay what do you think is
going to happen to the guy that's
slanging him if they can do an
investigation that guy's got to have to
answer some serious questions okay so
you think how many other people did he
sell them to sure what kind of side
hustle is he operating let me let me ask
you this question let me ask you
slippery slope here what they do if the
NFL finds out and this guy comes out and
says I'm selling vaccination card says
just so you know there's 30 other guys
that are selling it on every single team
on every team rampant someone because
because if a guy selling it on Tampa Bay
who's the poster child of the NFL
he's captain of that team which means
you don't think Tom knew this so Tom
knows this so I think I mean we can't
assume that he lives as well no if
you've read TV 12 also if it's odds if
we're playing the game of odds odds are
a captain's gonna know that this is
taking place if this has taken place
Roger Goodell is probably gonna want the
story to go away and not make a bigger
deal about it because he knows a Brady
in the Super Bowl gets more eyeballs
than a you know somebody else in the
Super Bowl so let's just address the
elephant in a room too if Aaron Rodgers
didn't get suspended Antonio Brown does
every black person in America Skip and
Shannon is going to go nuts for an
entire we just he didn't lie about
having a vaccine card though
wait wait are we are we talking about
nuance and facts
I mean half the world still thinks Kyle
Rittenhouse killed three black guys so
there's you know he's a white
supremacist come on man yeah yeah I mean
you know we live in a world where when
that poor bastard drove through not the
crazy bastard drove through the condo
drove through Wisconsin half the people
were waiting to see whether the driver
was white or black to see how to respond
this is just the reality of the
situation now it's not right it
disgusted me to the core of my freaking
being I hate everything about this so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]